question how is capitalism compatible
with your definition of good if it
requires ever-increasing uses of the
finite resources of the planet where
once depleted would mean our end well I
would say capitalism isn't compatible
with my definition of good if it
requires ever-increasing uses of the
finite resources of the planet but
that's by no means self-evident even
though the scuttlebutt let's say
especially among the environmentalist
oriented types who might have some
sympathy for by the way especially with
regards to ocean depletion there's a
huge argument and there has been for
many many years between the economists
and the biologists and this is a really
important thing to know and the
economists point out that human
ingenuity is such that were continually
able to make more with less and
certainly over the last well 500 years
especially in the last 150 years that's
just absolutely evident you know like
people say we're going to run out of
energy and I think that's absolutely
preposterous it's like it's as crazy as
thinking we're gonna run out of matter I
mean we're we're going through a bit of
a bottleneck right now because you know
the population is going to increase to
about 9 billion and then it's going to
decrease that's that's the most reliable
projections and 9 billion isn't a lot
more than we have now and you know
there's going to be some environmental
disruption as a consequence of that but
I don't think there's any reason to
assume at all that capitalism
necessarily requires ever-increasing
uses of the finite resources of the
planet it's also not obvious to what
degree the resources of the planet are
actually finite because we can
continually think up new uses for things
that nobody thought had any use at all
and so it depends to some degree on
whether or not you're willing to bet on
human imaginative Ness or you're going
to be a Malthusian pessimist and I'm not
saying that there aren't reasons for
both I'm just saying that it is by no
means self-evident that things are
getting worse you know like I can give
you an example so you know in the last
in the last 15 years the Millennium goal
for the UN was to have world poverty
like absolute poverty so that's less
dollar fifty day by fifty percent within
fifteen years that was actually reached
ahead of schedule and we've lifted
hundreds of millions of people into the
middle class over the last thirty years
and so there is an increasing inequality
in the West because the working class
has taken the brunt of that
say that redistribution to third-world
countries but by the same token you know
there's no starvation in the world
anymore except reading for reasons of
Mis distribution and and and political
purpose and people are becoming richer
and more educated all the time and you
know when we are waking up to our
planetary responsibilities once people
stop starving to death and having to
burn like dirt and and eat you know the
substandard food that they've scraped
out of the ground they do start to turn
their attention to things that might be
more aesthetic and so look I don't think
there's any reason to be pessimistic not
fundamentally and I guess the reason
that capitalism is compatible with my
definition of good I wouldn't say that
exactly I would say that I don't see an
alternative that has manifested itself
that doesn't have far more negative
consequences you know it's sort of a
minimal pessimism issue it's like well
this is the best devil that we have and
I do believe it is because the the
successful societies by any stretch of
the imagination by virtually any metric
are the capitalist societies and
certainly the case for example that the
Soviet Union demolished far more of its
natural resources to far less productive
consequence than the West did there's
evidence there's suggestions that
between ten and fifteen percent of the
total area of the Soviet Union has been
rendered more or less permanently
uninhabitable so the question is
compared to what